what's going on guys this is rob and in
this video i'm gonna make you guys an
expert on dane whitman also known as the
black knight because he's gonna be in
the eternals film here's the funny thing
about this dane whitman in the eternals
movie is probably gonna be way more
interesting than he's ever been in the
comics although i will say the ebony
blade in merlin is really what made dane
whitman cool when it came to marvel
comics so the idea behind this is that
dane whitman first appeared in avengers
issue number 47 in 1967 and he was
created by roy thomas and george tusca
now here's the thing about this the
popularity of dane whitman wasn't really
so much dane himself as it was the
circumstances under which he was
introduced or at least the initial
popularity he served and that's going to
be one of the reasons why as we kind of
go through this video that he's in a
perfect example of a character that
marvel introduced to was really popular
for a while and then dropped off so the
idea behind this is that dane whitman
being introduced here was really just
him and like a lab assistant named
norris and the whole point is that they
were basically messing with what were in
effect electromagnetic waves in an
effort to reach out and to basically
gain at least some understanding of
intelligent life that was out there
right to kind of bridge the gap between
humanity and alien races now the reality
is a fantastic four been doing this for
quite some time but in truth at the time
that marvel was publishing these comics
the nature of things is that while the
fantastic four were like space faring
and they were going on adventures and
things like that they didn't really
bring a lot of that stuff home but just
to say they weren't like introducing
alien races to earth on a regular basis
they would encounter them but it wasn't
like anything that you saw in the mid
2000s with like annihilation
annihilation conquest stuff like that a
lot of the early space-faring escapades
of marvel were limited to like a handful
of heroes and occasional contacts with
alien races and so the whole point
behind this the reason why this is
important is because during this time
roy thomas was actually in the process
of leading up to what is probably one of
the most important introductions of a
villain in the history of marvel comics
and it all came back to what were
basically the rebranded or recreated
masters of evil the idea here was that
at the time magneto and toad had
basically been whisked away by a cosmic
entity called the stranger who was
really more like a scientist than
anything else and the actions of dane
whitman had unwittingly released magneto
and toad which led to them coming back
to earth and basically recreating the
masters of evil of course along the way
they defeated dane whitman and his lab
assistant and so on and so forth during
that time what you also saw was an
explanation of dane whitman as it tied
into the original nathan garrett right
the first real black knight of the
modern era and here's an important thing
to understand so in 1955 marvel
introduced the black knight for the
first time but because of the fact that
it was really more atlas comics as
opposed to marvel comics during the
1950s what we could call marvel
basically told what were in effect
stories involving like science fiction
and like fantasy things like that it
wasn't really superheroes as you see
them today and so the stories of black
knight back then basically dealt with
the stories of sir percival of scandia
right the actual mythological black
knight that served alongside king arthur
now later on nathan garrett was
introduced as the black knight who was
villainous and a member of the original
masters of evil under magneto and was
actually basically destroyed by iron man
but the way the origin story is told
here with regards to dane whitman is
that in the final moments of nathan
garrett's death he basically regretted
all the villainous things he did and
told dane whitman to kind of go forward
and to actually take the mantle of black
knight and to be a hero and so what this
did is that during this time with
magneto returning and so on this is a
story that ran into issue number 48 and
then it ran all the way up into issue 53
and 54. now the reason why this is so
important and especially for those of
you guys who have seen our video on it
issue number 54 the return of the
masters of evil and all that kind of
stuff that dealt with a villain who was
known as the crimson cow the real
identity of the crimson cow where it was
initially revealed to be jarvis the
actual villain behind everything was
ultron and so that was basically uh it
was really black knight being introduced
along roy thomas's way to bringing
ultron into marvel comics and that's why
i say the introduction of black knight
was more circumstantial in reality as
far as i'm aware roy thomas created
black knight because he just wanted to
expand the mythos right just kind of
expand the avengers roster introduce new
things which was par for the course back
then right you saw it a lot when it came
to different writers but the important
thing is that despite these early
introductions where you did see dane
whitman actually aid the superheroes and
essentially defeating the crimson cow
and so on because they thought he was an
actual villain he just ended up taking
off now that was roy thomas's way of
removing black knight from the avengers
team temporarily and giving us marvel
superheroes number 17. and what marvel
superhero 17 did is it actually gave us
the backstory to the nature of the black
knight specifically involving merlin the
ebony blade all that kind of stuff and
so what ended up happening is that where
there was a castle that was inherited by
dane whitman that he looked to simply
just get rid of once he was there and he
actually traveled there by tour bus
which is kind of weird once he was there
he felt this almost kind of uh kind of
feeling right he was compelled to
explore the castle once he did he came
across basically what was kind of an urn
of sorts and when he lit it it basically
brought back the spirit of sir percy of
scandia and sir percy basically gave him
the whole explanation and simply saying
that at some point in time you had the
nephew of king arthur named mordred who
was looking to kill king arthur and to
conquer camelot and so what ended up
happening is that where percival was
introduced as what was kind of a buffoon
on the front face he would operate as
the black knight behind the scenes and
was actually probably the best of all
the different nights depending on who it
is that you talk to the issue with this
is that perceval had arrived to the
battle between mordred and king arthur
after king arthur was killed and so
where percival was ultimately struck
down we ended up learning a few things
happened the first is that merlin took
the essence of the percival family line
right so all those individuals who would
be born after sir percival escandia and
tied it directly to the sword so long as
a person has the sword and their
possession they are in effect immortal
but there are a few caveats the first is
that because the sword the ebony blade
was fashioned from a meteorite a person
who's wielding a weapon made of the same
meteorite can kill a person who is
wielding the ebony blade and can
actually destroy the ebony blade itself
the second thing and this is actually
something that was changed more recently
the second thing is that the ebony blade
itself had a kind of curse because the
sword was basically used in battle
bloodlust conflict things like that it
kind of developed a mind of its own to a
degree a sort of curse that as long as a
person wielded it the longer they wield
the sword the more they would desire
bloodlust and conflict and so that's why
you would see stories following this
that we can kind of you know mention in
passing here where dane whitman would
actually kind of lose himself where he
would go into something akin to like a
wolverine or a thor berserker rage where
he would just sort of lose his mind and
just kind of become insane because the
influence of the sword would override
him to a degree but the important thing
here is that because of the fact that he
is the the next member in the personal
line and because of the fact that this
basically uh gives him the ability to go
forward as the black knight in a more
heroic fashion he ended up taking the
ebony blade and then basically returned
to the avengers now during that time
this was kind of interesting about this
at the time marvel was in the process of
creating the defenders now as long as
you guys know from our discussion on the
defenders it was really just the results
of the fact that like doctor strange's
comics were cancelled they finished in a
series of crossover stories which people
loved so marvel gave us the defenders in
what was in effect uh kind of premier
comic and then following that the
defenders got their own story the other
thing about this is marvel was looking
to expand out beyond the states and as
part of that they were kind of
reshuffling the marvel landscape at the
time again all this really taking place
in the early 1970s going into the late
1970s and so what you saw here was two
things the first is that dane whitman
actually ended up becoming part of the
initial defender's team and then was
basically defeated right or at least you
know kind of uh put in stone by by
enchantress herself during that time
what marvel did is they whisked his
spirit away back to the days of the
crusades and then he basically handed
his uh his horse pegasus over to
valkyrie which is how valkyrie ended up
getting the pegasus horse the other part
of this and i don't really know if this
is true i'm just kind of guessing here
there's really nothing to confirm this
because the fact that black knight's
history was tied into supercivil
escandia arthurian legend all of which
really seemed to be a hallmark of
british history that with marvel looking
to expand out into marvel uk which at
the time were basically a series of just
stories either involving new tales of
captain britain or reprints of existing
marvel comics featuring spider-man and
characters like that that marvel
launched the hulk uk and so while this
did of course deal with the incredible
hulk what you saw were a series of
backup features that dealt with dane
whitman in the aftermath of the events
of defenders and that basically actually
saw him being brought to the modern day
in the body of a guy named garrington
and then in turn going forward and
helping captain britain different things
along those lines traveling back to the
days of uh of camelot and then like
helping to save it from mordred working
you know fighting alongside king arthur
all that kind of stuff it was kind of a
test i have to believe that marvel had
and asking the question is it one of
these things where where black knight
would be missed if we took him off the
avengers proper and we left him you know
left him in marvel uk or does he better
belong in marvel uk right is his
popularity as it existed at the time
enough to bolster our reach into the the
united kingdom and to grab a lot of that
that uk audience by essentially telling
stories that respect the mythology they
kind of grew up reading regardless of
the situation what you saw at the end of
the the hulk marvel uk run is you
actually saw dane whitman brought back
to the avengers roster now his initial
return was one that was actually kind of
fraught with conflict not so much on the
riding side but the in-story side and
the reason for that is because while you
did see the defenders finding a way to
return a spirit to his body that they
hadn't that the avengers themselves
hadn't gone on any kind of a mission to
save dane whitman and so the big issue
he had or really the big beef he had was
the avengers basically just left him
hanging and so initially there was a bit
of a skirmish there but then following
that he would actually join the team and
in reality if you tie in his involvement
with avengers 47 running up to the
events of 54 it makes him one of the
longest running members of the avengers
team as a whole now here's the biggest
issue that dane whitman faced the
reality was that during the the marvel
uk stuff that most of dane whitman's
ongoing enemies and you know mordred
stuff like that that was all largely
resolved there wasn't really a whole lot
to deal with when it came to the
avengers team and it kind of made sense
given the i wouldn't say lack of
popularity but given the fact that
marvel uk didn't really seem to grip uh
audiences in the way that marvel
expected it to captain britain was cool
excalibur was cool when it came along
later on but outside of that dane
whitman just didn't really seem to have
that kind of pull when they brought him
back onto the avengers it was kind of
the same thing people thought he was
cool but it wasn't one of these things
where it's like people were racing to
buy comics because it featured dane
whitman dane whitman was never on the
same level as like spider-man or captain
america or iron man these guys had
really really really compelling stories
ultimately dane whitman didn't and that
was a result of a lot of people who just
seemed to kind of write him incorrectly
but regardless of how you slice it you
saw a few things take place over there
the ebony blade always kind of seemed to
be in the forefront it was always one of
these things of like is this the issue
where the ebony blade is going to
finally corrupt dane whitman or or where
it was given to somebody like marina the
wife of name of the submariner who went
crazy whatever the case happens to be
it's one of these things where there
just wasn't a whole lot of emphasis
there now a lot of this went into into
1988 and marvel actually made one of the
best decisions they possibly could the
reason why is because with issue number
297 that focus on the conclusion of all
these different crazy cross-time capers
featuring king the conqueror and the
existing roster of the avengers
basically resigned and so what marvel
did because dane whitman was part of
that they wanted to kind of shuffle him
around the marvel landscape and see if
there were just other stories that would
be more compelling if they featured him
and so what they actually did is they
had him work alongside thor where he
would basically have to be a protector
of asgard and face off against the
villain known as seth the problem with
this is that no one really cared
so by the time he got to thor issue
number 400 that what ended up happening
is dane whitman was basically just kind
of stuck in in the form of an inanimate
statue when he was locked in stone again
and so going into 1990 roy thomas was
brought back to kind of rework the black
knight mythos to a degree and it
actually worked pretty well to be honest
with you guys so it was basically black
knight vol 2 which was kind of the
second iteration of a black knight solo
series as limited as it was
again like the original in 1955 was
largely considered to be volume one but
the idea behind this was that you had a
woman named victoria bentley now
victoria bentley was one of these
characters that marvel kind of teased
could be super powerful but they never
really seemed to do a whole lot with
she'd been around since 1963 so it's not
like she was new she'd been around for
quite some time it was one of these
things where her initial involvement
actually dealt with beer and mordo
kidnapping her and then realizing how
powerful she would be and then using her
as a pawn to bring in doctor strange and
so on and so forth but marvel just never
really seemed to elevate her to any
significant role but the idea behind
this was that because of the fact that
dane woodman was locked in a stone form
he was sent back to his castle he was
tended to by victoria bentley and then
her attempt was to bring dane whitman
back what she actually ended up doing
was placing the spirit of sir percy of
scandia in the body of dane whitman
which was actually an attempt by roy
thomas to ask the question would people
want to see sir percy of scandia instead
right does just no one care about dane
whitman
the result is that people were
interested in seeing whitman they just
didn't really find him to be compelling
in the stories as they were written at
the time which is a hugely important
thing because in the 90s marvel would
totally change whitman up but the idea
behind this is that with whitman being
restored to his physical body after
percy of scandia just kind of leads he
basically just corporates marvel did a
couple different things the most notable
of this is they actually removed the
idea of the bloodlust curse from the
ebony blade and the sense that it was
just kind of removed from the scenario
as a whole following that and going into
avengers issue number 329 what you saw
was kind of a sort of tease of slowly
bringing dane whitman back as part of
the avengers he wasn't fully thrown onto
the team instead you actually got some
stories where he was more of kind of
like the guy they hit up when no one
else can show up so really more of like
a substitute member if you want to call
him that like a reserve member or
something along those lines and then
actually what you ended up seeing a
little bit later on in avengers issue
number 343 is that he became a full-on
member of the team now this coincided
directly with an event called operation
galactic storm at the same time in 343
dane whitman walked away from the ebony
blade in its entirety because the curse
was kind of re-emerging now because of
the fact that this was the 1990s and
because the goal of marvel was to create
more fast-paced high-octane stories
super high technology things like that
then what you saw was dane whitman
getting rid of the ebony blade and
replacing it with what was in effect
like a photon sword it was really more
akin to a lightsaber if we're being
honest with ourselves but operation
galactic storm is probably one of the
most important stories that has nothing
to do with the avengers and really has
more to do with the cree right and to
kind of give you guys a little bit of an
aside here for those of you guys who are
interested the idea of the cree race and
the reason why they look the way they do
is because there came a point when one
of them managed to get their their hands
on an object that was called the crystal
of ultimate vision the problem with this
is that if you got your hands on the
crystal and you intended to use it for
nefarious purposes it would freeze the
evolutionary process of your race which
is exactly what happened to the creek
the idea of operation galactic storm was
for the supreme intelligence the leader
of the kree to initiate a giant war with
the shia race which was really an empire
that i think
in my mind is actually bigger than the
cree themselves but regardless it wiped
out like 99 of the cree race which jump
started their evolutionary process that
was kind of the significance of the the
entire event itself but the funny thing
about this is that the supreme
intelligence was actually killed at the
end of the story by dane whitman so
again it was a a pretty cool little
involvement there to say like this guy
is one involved in more space-faring
escapades he's really more of a hero who
can fight alongside the avengers and
like space-faring events as opposed to
just whatever earth stuff happens to be
but then at the same time it kind of
boosted his popularity a little bit the
other thing that took place during this
time that's probably the one of the more
notable things to happen to dane whitman
even though it only lasted about 20
issues was between avengers 355 and 375
and this is when dane whitman basically
became the gan joseon for cersei the
whole idea behind this is that the
eternals have their own customs right
their their own situation so on and so
forth by and large the eternals never
really have dealings with humanity
outside of the role assigned to them by
the celestials themselves which is to
say eternals don't usually date or
associate with humanity in any real
romantic way you never really saw
something play out the way that it did
where cersei had actually chosen a human
as what was basically her life mate and
that's the game joseph now it's also uh
the actual name of the ceremony so it's
like if you get married right like you
call it a wedding but instead of calling
the person you're with your husband or
your wife you call them you're wedded
right or you call it like you you call
them your wedding right it's the name of
the ceremony but also the name of the
world that the person plays now a lot of
this has to do with what was going on in
the eternals comics at the time the fact
that uh cersei was basically possessed
she wasn't really in total control of
her faculties it's not in the the sense
that like dane whitman manipulated her
but it was one of these things where
marvel kind of crafted this love
triangle now truth to tell it was one of
these things where marvel was trying to
duplicate the popularity of the love
triangle between like wolverine cyclops
and jean it didn't work no one wanted it
but the evolution of dane whitman as he
lived with the eternals was really cool
because you saw him going on different
adventures and things like that and
fighting alongside the eternals and so
during that point in time i loved the
character of dane whitman and for
reasons that i will never fully
understand marvel threw him into the
ultraverse now for those of you guys who
don't know what that is the ultraverse
was a line of comics that was created by
a company called malibu between 1993 and
1997. it was at the height of like the
comic book collector market right
everybody was buying comics hoping they
would have a whole bunch of value later
on down the line this basically dealt
with something called the avengers ultra
force crossover which actually
introduced the lost infinity stone and
the being nemesis none of that matters
if anybody ever tells you that it's cool
or it's in continuity they're lying
that's it was never cool and it was
never in continuity but the thing about
this is that it was sort of based off
the original infinity gauntlet story
right the idea that thanos had just kind
of described the creation of the
infinity stones is saying like once upon
a time there was a being and they were
lonely so they dispersed their essence
into the stones and then it created
everything in existence marvel used that
as part of the ultraverse avengers
crossover to say like that person was
actually nemesis and they existed in
like this imprint in this alternate
reality that was created by malibu it
was kind of bad the important thing here
though is that you actually had dane
whitman who was basically written out of
marvel comics and stayed in ultraverse
as part of the ultra force for quite
some time which ran as part of
ultraverse unlimited and by issue number
two it was canceled and he was rolled
back over into uh into the main marvel
universe and so going into the mid-1990s
there were a couple stories the first
one was black knight exodus number one
and the second one was actually a
crossover event between avengers west
coast avengers x-men vol 2 and uncanny
x-men called blood ties and basically it
had a couple things happening the first
thing is that dane whitman was thrown
back into the past during the crusades
of his ancestors body eobard garrington
and actually ended up encountering
bennett du perry who would go on to
become exodus but more so than that he
actually faced off against apocalypse
which was kind of cool the other part of
this is that because of his time travel
capers because of the fact that his
spirit had been like physically removed
from his body and so on it allowed
marvel to kind of nullify the gan joseon
that had been created between himself
and cersei and this actually allowed
marvel to kind of roll him on to the
heroes for hire one of the downsides
about this is that following the
conclusion of the first run of heroes
for hire the series just never really
recovered because fans were so mad about
how it ended and so in truth by the time
you got to the 1990s and i would say
this is probably reminiscent of multiple
multiple titles that marvel had at the
time the heroes for hire kind of felt
like the island of misfit toys that's
where you would shuffle characters off
to until you figured out what you wanted
to do with them sometimes it would just
be writing them out and they would just
be gone forever other times they would
just kind of move them on to something
else for the character of dane whitman
marvel had actually moved him on to the
avengers and excalibur at first it was
excalibur vol 2 with issues one through
four and then eventually you got to new
excalibur with issues 10 through 15. and
the reason why this was important is
because you saw him kind of engaging in
some time travel escapades where he
would travel to the past he would travel
to the present it was a point where he
helped merlin fight some dragons but
what ended up happening is he went on
kind of a personal quest to hunt for
what was basically the ebony blade and
marvel removed him from the landscape
for like a decade right he was gone for
10 years the funny thing about this is
that by the time he got to the mid-2000s
so about 2006 running up to about 2008
while we have talked about this before
and kind of the great reshuffling under
joe casada the dane whitman was brought
back but this guy was a pinball he was
just bouncing all over the place right
he was just everywhere all over the
place he was part of captain britain he
was part of euroforce which was a really
weird kind of team and series of events
that took place the whole thing behind
this though is that marvel never knew
what to do with this guy right marvel
never knew where to put him or how to
handle him or anything like that he
would appear here he would appear there
and that would basically be it but in
truth when you had events like secret
invasion and stuff like that he didn't
play any massive roles in this the funny
thing is that even more recently it's
been the case right running from the mid
2000s up until now there haven't really
been any major stories involving the
black knight if anything the stories
that you see him in are really more
reminiscent of the early avengers
stories he was in where he was just kind
of there and he would do some stuff and
then like the day would be saved and
that would be it one of the more notable
things that happened is that one as part
of jason aaron's avengers run he was in
possession of the phoenix force for a
time but then of course ended up losing
it and in fact it was kind of crazy
because he ended up facing off against
the red widow and she's the one that
took him out at the same time what you
also got during donnie kate's run on on
venom as part of the king and black
event is you got this adjustment to the
nature of the ebony blade and it was
kind of a cool thing it's by no means
significant right this is not a game
changer if anything i imagine marvel
probably did it because of the fact that
the eternals movie is coming out and
it's just a small modification designed
to bring the character of black knight
more in line with the eternals film
whatever form it's going to take as far
as this character evolution and progress
goes but the whole thing behind this is
that where the ebony blade was believed
to have a curse that whoever wielded it
would basically become more bloodlusted
the stronger they became instead when
you had black knight who was essentially
spoken to by noel the symbiote god right
the main villain behind the king and
black storyline the guy trying to
conquer the world and the universe and
everything that what he said it doesn't
actually work that way that merlin had
really lied to uh dane whitman himself
which kind of made sense because merlin
had always sort of been a pretty
duplicitous guy what's told the dane
whitman is that the the curse of the
sword or the nature of the sword is that
it brings out all the negative emotions
of the person who's wielding it in a lot
of ways it made a lot more sense as
opposed to like the original curse the
original curse is cool and it's kind of
a hallmark of the character but it makes
more sense to say that the sword just
draws on the negative emotions of its
wielder and just drives them to become
the darker version of themselves now of
what value that has and what significant
it has we don't know because literally
that story just ended so i have no idea
what's going to go on with the future of
dane whitman in marvel comics in reality
i would say the future of dane whitman
in in the comic book landscape is really
going to depend on what they do with
them in the movies right like if they
you know have a story just go off in a
totally different direction from what
you saw in the uh in the comics then the
new comic stories will follow that
whereas if the movie depiction is more
in line with the comic book stories then
you'll find the direction that dane
whitman goes in will be more in line
with his old school comic stuff right in
this day and age the comics follow the
movies not really the other way around
so with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace